Hey, it's John Hamm. I got here early and set my tech up very quickly, so of course I'm waiting for three idiots. Welcome to Smartless. Oh my God, that gives me, is that Yaz? Yeah, yes it is. That brings me back to, uh, I met, uh, I went to Chicago, uh, once to, uh, work the phones at a charity, uh, or a, uh, a, a, uh, a telethon. Jason? What have you done with my Jason? Yeah. And I, uh, I met, uh, I met, uh, I met a, I met a, a girl there and she was also working the phones and we fell in love and and i i was 15 and i went i went back home i talked to my mom about this love i fell in with this girl in chicago for a whole full week she said why don't you go back and see her i'll take you i'll go with you i was like great my mom and i got back on a plane the following weekend went back to chicago and i had the most you told her you fell in love
嘿，我是乔恩·哈姆。我来得早，科技设备也收拾得极快，所以当然啦，我在等三个笨蛋。欢迎收听 Smartless。天哪，那让我，那是 Yaz 乐队吗？对，没错，确实是。这让我想起，呃，我遇到，呃，我去了芝加哥，呃，有一次去，呃，在一个慈善机构接听热线，或者一个，呃，募捐电视节目。杰森？你把我家的杰森怎么了？对。然后我，呃，我遇到，呃，我遇到，呃，我遇到一个，我遇到一个，呃，那里的女孩，她也在接听热线，我们坠入爱河，而我，我当时15岁，我回家了，我跟妈妈谈起这份爱，我在芝加哥爱上了这个女孩，整整一个星期，她说：“你为什么不回去见她？我带你去，我跟你一起去。”我说：“太棒了！”我和妈妈在接下来的周末坐飞机回到了芝加哥，我度过了最……你告诉她你坠入爱河了
with a girl yeah working the phone banks with me at this telethon and we had a magical weekend and that was that. All we listened to was Yaz the whole weekend. Yeah, only you. It's one of the best songs ever. Now, Jason, did you know that the guy who wrote all those Yaz songs wrote all those Erager songs and wrote Depeche Mode songs? Really?
和一个女孩，没错，就在这次募捐活动中跟我一起接听热线电话，我们度过了一个神奇的周末，事情就是这样。那个周末我们听的全是 Yaz 的歌。没错，只有你。那是史上最棒的歌曲之一。杰森，你知道吗，写了所有那些 Yaz 歌曲的那个家伙，也写了所有那些 Erasure 的歌，还写了赶时髦乐团（Depeche Mode）的歌？真的吗？
Vince Clark. Not all of them, but a lot of them. Yeah, Benz Clark was the writer of Yaz, and then he went to Depeche Mode and wrote, you know, just can't get enough in all those kind of songs. Then he left Depeche Mode and went to Eurasia and wrote all the notes. So now, let me ask you this. Here's a little, Sean, you might know that.
文斯·克拉克（Vince Clark）。不是全部，但很多都是。对，文斯·克拉克是 Yaz 的词曲作者，然后他去了赶时髦乐团，写了，你知道的，诸如《Just Can't Get Enough》之类的那种歌。然后他离开了赶时髦乐团，加入了 Erasure，写了所有的……所以现在，我问你个问题。这有个小问题，肖恩，你可能知道。
You probably do. The name of the lead singer of Yaz. What was her name? Allison Moyet. Wow. Again, I said you may know this, but yeah. Okay. Well, do you guys...
你大概知道。Yaz 乐队主唱的名字。她叫什么名字？艾莉森·莫耶（Allison Moyet）。哇。再说一次，我说你可能知道这个，但好吧。好吧，你们……
Well, do you guys... Yeah, go ahead. Did you guys know what the music festival was where... What is the new game show? We have. Queen was the headliner, and Yaz led in for them. It was called Yaz Queen.
好吧，你们……对，说吧。你们知道那个音乐节是什么吗？……那个新的游戏皇后是什么？皇后乐队是压轴嘉宾，Yaz 为他们暖场。那个音乐节叫“Yaz 皇后”（Yaz Queen）。
And it was... It predated Lollapalooza. I can't believe I'm laughing at that. That's stupid. Look who had a good one. Yes, Queen. Even a stopped clock. I want to ask you guys
而且它……它比 Lollapalooza 音乐节还要早。我不敢相信我在笑这个。太蠢了。看谁讲得好。是的，女王。破钟也有准的时候。我想问你们
with the worst trouble in Uganda as a kid because here's why. Because whenever I'm like five minutes late to rehearsal here in Chicago, you know, I feel like you get in trouble like I was a kid, so I was talking to Scotty about that. And Scotty's like, I asked Scotty, what's the worst trouble you got in his kid? Scotty got his mouth washed out with soap
小时候在乌干达遇到过最糟糕的麻烦吗？原因如下。因为每当我在芝加哥排练迟到哪怕五分钟的时候，你知道的，我就会觉得好像惹上了麻烦，就像我还是个孩子的时候一样，所以我跟斯科蒂聊过这个。斯科蒂就说，我问斯科蒂，你小时候惹过最糟糕的麻烦是什么？斯科蒂被用肥皂洗过嘴
from the nuns and Catholic school. He was about six or seven years old. And he got in trouble because he was making fart noises on his arm in the bathroom. Oh, boy. And they literally took soap and they really literally scrubbed his mouth. Why, they should have scrubbed his armpit. Right. But you know what he did?
天主教学校的修女干的。他当时大约六、七岁。他惹上麻烦是因为他在洗手间里用胳膊制造放屁的声音。天哪。他们真的拿肥皂，字面意思上狠狠地刷了他的嘴。切，他们应该刷他的胳膊窝。没错。但你知道他做了什么吗？
He breathed in to make his mouth all dry so that it wouldn't suds up. You got under our guest or? I mean, wow. What do you? Are you trying to. Will, will, can you top Scotty's dry wash? I mean, there have been a lot of stories of heroes over the years And that is really, people really, when their backs against the wall
他吸气，好让嘴里变干，这样就不会起泡沫了。你把我们嘉宾的风头抢了还是怎么？我是说，哇。你打算……威利，威利，你能超过斯科蒂的干洗记录吗？我是说，这些年来有很多英雄的故事，而这真的是，当人们被逼入绝境时
Forced to come up with, right? Alois got outsmarted them. Yeah. You know, there's no fluid in my mouth, so you will not get suds, ma'am. But I always thought that was like a not real thing That you got your mouth washed out. But he got his mouth. That once happened to me.
被迫想出的办法，对吧？阿洛伊斯（Alois）智胜了他们。没错。你知道的，“我嘴里没有唾液，所以你弄不出泡沫，修女。”但我一直以为小时候嘴里被用肥皂洗这事是假的。但他真的被洗了。这事也曾在海军身上发生过。
Right. Yeah. I one time my mom went to hit me with a wooden spoon, true story. And I was in the kitchen and I was being mouthy. I guess. I can't imagine how. Probably not. And I was sweeping.
对。没错。我妈有一次想用木勺打我，千真万确的故事。当时我在厨房里，嘴里不干净。我猜吧。我无法想象怎么个不干净法。可能吧。我当时在扫地。
I was holding a broom and I was sweeping. And I said something and she went to swat me with the wooden spoon and I put the broom up to block it and it broke the wooden spoon in half. My timing was perfect and it snapped it in half. And there was a moment of like, what just happened? And then we both burst into laughter. Oh, that's nice. Yeah. Because you said you better step off.
我手里拿着一把扫帚在扫地。然后我说了句什么，她就想用木勺拍我，我把扫帚举起来挡了一下，结果把木勺给打断成两半了。我时机抓得太完美了，“啪”地一声把它折断成两半。有那么一瞬间，大家都在想：“刚才发生了什么？”然后我们俩都爆发出大笑。哦，那挺好。没错。因为你对她说“你最好放尊重点”。
Well, just because I was able to block her so easily. Right. Just the whole topic of abuse and families is... Well, she went to hit me on the butt with the wooden spoon. Next time does she come at you with a metal spatula? Because that's what I would have done. I would have learned my lesson. You know, I know.
好吧，只是因为我能这么轻松地挡下她。没错。虐待和家庭这个话题……好吧，她想用木勺打我的屁股。下次她是不是会拿着金属铲子来找你？因为我要是你的话，我就会这么做。我会吸取教训的。你知道的，我懂。
I guess these days I don't even want to get into the broader conversation because... Yeah, well, no, hang on a second. Let's talk about how you discipline your children and what you advocate for. Yeah, I want to open that up. And I'd like to open it up to the world. And not only that, I want to hear their opinions on it. You would never do anything.
我想现在我甚至不想深入探讨这个更广泛的话题，因为……好吧，等一下。我们来谈谈你是怎么管教孩子的，你支持什么样的方式。对，我想展开这个话题。我想向全世界开放这个话题。不仅如此，我还想听听他们对此的意见。你才不会做什么呢。
No, of course. Guys, here we go. Hi. Ready? Might if I got a burp. I'm not going to burp right now. Would this guest appreciate something like that? He wouldn't care.
不，当然不会。伙计们，我们开始吧。嗨。准备好了吗？我可能想打个嗝。我等会儿再打嗝。这位嘉宾会欣赏这种事吗？他才不在乎呢。
He wouldn't care. You didn't even wait for our answer. You said, do you mind if I burp? And then you just were going to do it. You didn't. I was going to. Why bother saying it? It's just.
他才不在乎。你甚至都没等我们回答。你说“介意我打个嗝吗？”然后你就要直接打了。你才没……我本来打算打的。为什么还要说出来呢？这只是……
Was it a false alarm? Because I didn't see you burp. Yeah. No, it came up. It was right on the, whenever this is part of your throat is. You are, I will say, after having been on the road with you for 10 days, almost two weeks. I'm a burper. You're quite a burper.
是个虚假警报吗？因为我没看见你打嗝。对。不，涌上来了。就在那儿，就在你喉咙的这个部位。我得说，跟你一起在路上巡演了10天，将近两个星期之后。我是个会打嗝的人。你确实是个很会打嗝的人。
Oh, yeah, you are a loud burper like me. You like to, you like to, you like to, yeah, no. You like to kind of yell your burrs. Well, Jason, you like to do the burp that's almost, like, you pretend as if you're about to throw up and you go, but I do the same thing. I do the same thing. I will say that to both of your credits, you, neither one of you have, bubble problems from the other end.
哦，是的，你跟我一样是个声音很大的打嗝大王。你喜欢，你喜欢，你喜欢，没错。你喜欢那种大喊大叫式的打嗝。好吧，杰森，你喜欢打那种几乎像是，假装你要呕吐然后发出“呃”的那种嗝，但我也会这样。我也这样做。我要为你们俩点赞的是，你们俩都没有，另一端的气泡问题。
No. I don't have too many bubble problems. Bubble problems from the other end. Yeah. This guy's amazing. Let's get, I don't want to waste this time. He's received guys 16 Emmy nominations for one television show. Huh.
没有。我没有太多气泡问题。另一端的气泡问题。没错。这家伙太棒了。我们开始吧，我不想浪费时间。伙计们，他凭一部电视剧获得了16项艾美奖提名。哈。
Herring. Hang on that. Yeah, I'm going to say, well, wait, so that's 16 years. Well, no. It could be for other things. Multiple. It could be writing, producing, and... Yeah, sure.
等等。等等这个。好吧，我要说，等等，那是16年。好吧，不。可能是因为其他事情。多个方面。可能是编剧、制片，以及……没错，当然。
He's one of the... He's one of the rarers that's known for both comedy and drama, and his films are some of the best ever made. This, I didn't know about him. He returned to his high school in St. Louis, Missouri, to teach eighth grade acting, and one of his students was Ellie Kemper. I didn't know that.
他是少数几个……他是极少数既以喜剧闻名又以剧情片闻名的人之一，他的电影是有史以来拍得最好的几部。这个，我之前不知道。他回到位于密苏里州圣路易斯的母校高中教八年级表演，他的学生之一就是艾丽·坎珀（Ellie Kemper）。我不知道这个。
Really? He does love this, and I hope we talk about it for the entire episode. He's an avid golfer. Uh-oh. It's none other than the dashingly handsome, the talented... Very relatable.
真的吗？他真的很喜欢这个，我希望我们能聊上一整集。他是个狂热的高尔夫球手。哦噢。这不正是那位风度翩翩、英俊潇洒、才华横溢的……非常有共鸣。
John Hamm. What? What? Do I get any of that, right, John? Yeah, you get it all right. I did really. Him. You have to say,
乔恩·哈姆。什么？什么？我这话说得对吗，乔恩？对，你全说对了。我真的……他。你得说，
I don't think I've ever been immediately put in a good mood from any of our previous guests. It was a pretty low bar given the fart, burp conversation that I stumbled on to. Do you want to join in? You just perked me up.
我想我从来没有因为我们之前的任何一位嘉宾，而立刻拥有这么好的心情。考虑到我刚才撞上的放屁、打嗝的话题，这标准其实挺低的。你想加入进来吗？你刚才让我精神一振。
Hi, boys. John. What's happening, Ham? It's been a minute. How you doing? Oh, John. The best or nothing. Yes, exactly.
嗨，伙计们。乔恩。怎么回事，哈姆？好久不见。最近怎么样？哦，乔恩。要么最好，要么不做。对，没错。
We got three car guys on here. Sean, get a fucking car contract Or how about a motorcycle, Sean? Let me hear you sell a Yamaha right now. Okay, ready? Hey, guys, are you in a hurry? Get a Yamaha. Wait, you're advocating.
我们这儿有三个汽车发烧友。肖恩，快去签个汽车代言合同吧，或者摩托车怎么样，肖恩？让我听听你现在怎么推销雅马哈。好吧，准备好了吗？嘿，伙计们，你们赶时间吗？买辆雅马哈。等等，你这是在鼓吹……
They're going to be like, no, no, no, we don't want to advocate for people to speed if you're in a hurry. Hey, guys, pissed off at those dudes cutting line by going right in between your cars. Get a Yamaha. Hey, guys, why don't we weave in and out of traffic? Hey, we make musical instruments and motorcycles. That's not weird. Hey, you can play our car. Do you want to ride up to your baby grand in style?
他们会说：“不，不，不，如果赶时间的话，我们可不主张大家超速。”嘿，伙计们，对那些直接开进车流缝隙里加塞的家伙很不爽吗？买辆雅马哈。嘿，伙计们，我们为什么不在车流里左穿右插呢？嘿，我们既制造乐器，又制造摩托车。这可一点也不奇怪。嘿，你可以弹奏我们的汽车。你想风风光光地骑到你的大钢琴前吗？
Hey, I wonder how many products Yamaha makes. They make musical instruments. They make pianos, obviously. They make guitars? I know they make violins because I had one in third grade. A Yamaha violin? I've never heard. I believe I did.
嘿，我想知道雅马哈生产多少种产品。他们生产乐器。他们显然生产钢琴。他们生产吉他吗？我知道他们生产小提琴，因为我三年级时有一把。雅马哈小提琴？我从没听说过。我想我确实有。
How long did you play violin? I think until about sixth grade. And then... And then it just got too... I could never really read music. it got too complicated. I just, I could, I could, I can still kind of do it from memory, like that weird, long, long term memory where you remember lyrics of songs,
你拉小提琴拉了多久？我想大概拉到六年级吧。然后……然后它就变得太……我从来没真正学会看谱。它变得太复杂了。我只是，我能，我还能凭记忆勉强拉一点，就像那种奇怪的、长期的记忆，你能记住歌曲的歌词，
but like, you know, your mom's birthday somehow, you forget. It's the weirdest thing, how you're bringing. Quick, what's your mom's birthday? February 1st. Oh, well, that seems that's, oh, who would forget that? That's a very easy day. Did you move on to a different instrument, or did you just say screw it? No, I think that's when, like, sports became kind of paramount.
但不知怎么的，你妈妈的生日你却忘了。这是最奇怪的事情，你的大脑是怎么运作的。快说，你妈妈的生日是什么时候？2月1日。哦，好吧，看来那是，哦，谁会忘掉这个？那是个非常容易记住的日子。你后来换了别的乐器，还是说干脆算了吧？不，我想那是体育运动开始变得至关重要的时期。
I just did that. What did you jump into in sports? Football, baseball, swimming, soccer, basketball, what have you. Were you kind of good at all of them? I was better at football and baseball, but I was kind of good at a lot of stuff. This is the high school I went to. He says, Burroughs baseball. This is my baseball shirt from 10th grade.
我就去搞体育了。你在体育方面都玩些什么？橄榄球、棒球、游泳、英式足球、篮球，诸如此类。你这些运动都挺擅长吗？我更擅长橄榄球和棒球，但很多项目我都还算擅长。这是我读的高中。他说，巴勒斯（Burroughs）棒球队。这是我高中的棒球队服，10年级的。
Is that your actual 10th grade T-shirt? Yeah, yeah. From congratulations. What brand is that? That's really holding up. I think it's a champion. Will's high school T-shirts now, a beautiful midrift that you. wear every once in a while.
那是你10年级真正的T恤吗？对，对。来自，恭喜。这是什么牌子的？质量真好。我觉得是 Champion 牌的。威利的高中T恤现在，那迷人的露腰装，你偶尔还会穿。
It's turned into an homage to 90s, Britney Spears. Jason's high school T-shirt is a Warner Bros. A lot tour shirt. It's a tank. It's got a cap to match it. It's from upfronts.
它已经变成了对90年代布兰妮·斯皮尔斯的致敬。杰森的高中T恤是一件华纳兄弟巡演T恤。这是一件背心。它还有一顶配套的帽子。那是来自电视推介会（Upfronts）。
They came in after Al. It's from Upfronts. 1984. Johnny. I didn't know that about high school where you graduated with an English degree and then went back to your high school to teach you because that's kind of like a...
它们在阿尔之后问世。那是来自电视推介会。1984年。乔尼。我不知道关于高中还有这出，你在那儿拿到了英语学位，然后又回高中去教书，因为那有点像……
I'm one of the few people that loved high school. I did too. I went to a really excellent high school, the aforementioned John Burroughs High School in St. Louis, Missouri. And we had like crazy, you know, we were encouraged to try everything. So it was like arts and sports and academics and everybody was sort of encouraged to achieve and do well.
我是少数几个热爱高中生活的人之一。我也是。我上了一所非常优秀的高中，也就是前面提到的位于密苏里州圣路易斯的约翰·巴勒斯高中。我们有各种疯狂的，你知道的，我们被鼓励去尝试一切。所以就像艺术、体育和学术，每个人都被鼓励去取得成就、表现出色。
And that sort of was the ethos of the whole joint. you know, you didn't have to be good at it, but you had to try. And that was the fun of it all. And getting exposed to, like, all of these different disciplines was really cool. And it wasn't, you know, there weren't like the jocks and the nerds and the sportos or whatever the Eidie McClurg thing from Ferris Bueller is of all of the gradations. Nice call on Eiddy McClure. Come on.
这正是整个学校的精神内核。你知道的，你不需要样样精通，但你必须去尝试。这就是这一切的乐趣所在。接触到所有这些不同的学科，真的很酷。而且，你知道的，没有什么运动员、书呆子、运动健将之类的高中阶层划分，就像《春天不是读书天》里的伊迪·麦克利格（Edie McClurg）所代表的那些阶层一样。Eidy McClure 这个梗用得好。拜托。
You got to know McClure. You got to have McClure at the top of the... I did a show with her for five years. Did you really? That woman, yeah. Hey, so, but now, John, don't, don't. Don't be falsely modest here, but I've got you between the jocks and the nerds, I've got you heavier over on the jocks side. Yeah, the dials twisted a little to that side for sure.
你得懂 McClure。你得把 McClure 放在……我跟她合作过一档节目，整整五年。真的吗？那个女人，对。嘿，所以，但是现在，乔恩，别，别。别在这儿假谦虚了，但在运动员和书呆子之间，我觉得你更偏向运动员那一侧。对，指针确实稍微偏向那一边。
You did very well in high school. Was that a fair statement? Yeah, I graduated with honors and, yeah. That's not what I'm talking about. Yeah, yeah, it is. You did okay? Did you do all right? Okay.
你在高中表现得非常好。这么说公平吗？对，我以优异的成绩毕业，而且，对。我说的不是这个。对，对，就是这个。你过得挺好？你一切都好吗？好吧。
Why do you keep winking at him? It's not winking. No, we're talking about sports. Did you score, did you score a lot? Scored a lot of points. Yeah. Scored a lot of points. I don't know.
你为什么一直对她挤眉弄眼？这不是挤眉弄眼。不，我们在谈论体育。你得分了吗，你得了很多分吗？得了挺多分的。对。得了挺多分的。我不知道。
Did you put a lot in the bucket? That sounds good. was he had to play a lot of defense. Put a lot of balls in the basket. I don't know where this metaphor is going. Jason, is Amanda got you like on a no-fly list? What's going on right now? Are you not?
你在篮筐里投进了很多球吗？听起来不错。意思是他的防守任务很重。往篮筐里塞了很多球。我不知道这个隐喻要走向何方。杰森，阿曼达（Amanda）是不是把你列入禁飞名单了？现在是怎么回事？你到底怎么了？
What's going on? Well, then how did, all right, so then you start to feather in... Jason, fix your hair. I'm sorry. You start to feather in some theater, right? Did that, did that... Feather and then braids some theater. And then did you braid anything in?
怎么回事？好吧，那么，你是怎么开始涉足……杰森，理理你的头发。抱歉。你开始涉足一些戏剧，对吧？那个，那个……涉足并编织了一些戏剧。然后你还编了什么进去？
I don't have a lot of terms. Will's so tired of my shit. It's new to John, so be hush, hush. There was some theater feathering for sure. Did the jocks ostracize you for that? That's a new one, well. I'm going to feather that one in. Did they ostracize you, and then did the nerds embrace and receive you?
我没那么多词汇。威利对我的废话简直厌烦透顶。这对乔恩来说是新鲜事，所以安静点，安静点。确实涉足了一点戏剧。运动员们为此把你排挤在外了吗？这倒是个新词，威利。
Like I said, no, not really, because there was a real blend of, talk about feathering. Both groups were feathered together quite well. Yeah. And the jocks were all over. We did, the senior production, senior year production was Godspell. So, as in most high school productions, They were, you know, 35 roles, and they split up roles, and you would do half a song. With the exception of me who played Judas and the kid who played Jesus.
我要把这个词用上。他们把你排挤在外了吗，然后书呆子们张开双臂接纳了你？就像我说的，不，并没有，因为有一种真正的融合，说到融合。这两拨人融合得相当好。对。运动员们无处不在。我们当时排练，高三那年的毕业演出是《福音》（Godspell）。所以，就像大多数高中的演出一样，有大约35个角色，他们把角色分摊，你可能只演半首歌。除了我——我扮演犹大，还有一个扮演耶稣的小孩。
So, yeah, you know, it was fun and exciting, and it was, you know, it was something to do. And it just was encouraged. So we all did it. It was fun. If I looked at your high school picture, did you have luxurious hair? I had a good flow in 89. Sure. Real good flow.
所以，是的，你知道的，这既有趣又激动人心，而且，你知道的，这总算有事可做。学校也非常鼓励。所以我们都参与了。很好玩。如果我看看你的高中照片，你当时有一头浓密飘逸的头发吗？我在89年时发型很棒。真的，发型非常飘逸。
Real sound. It's valid, huh? Bateman-esque, I would say. Jason, this is, I think Ham's giving you a run for your money. He's got a great flow. He can have it. John wins every category with any man on the planet. You know?
真的很不错。很有型，对吧？我觉得有点像贝特曼（Bateman）式的。杰森，我觉得哈姆快要赶上你了。他的发型太棒了。他可以拥有它。乔恩在任何男人的任何评比中都能稳操胜券。你知道吗？
You're foolish. You just chase the silver with him. Listen, it's just nice to be nominated in any category. Wait, Johnny, when you went back to teach at your high school, was there anybody still there that you knew? Oh, yeah. Yeah, tons of teachers that I knew and loved. So it was kind of a true.
你太傻了。你居然跟他比银发。听着，能在任何类别里获得提名就已经很好了。等等，乔尼，当你回到母校教书时，里面还有你认识的人吗？哦，对。对，有成吨我认识并且喜爱的老师。所以这感觉像是一个真正的……
Now teaching beside them? Yeah, yeah. They were now colleagues. which is really cool. That's crazy. And in fact, the guy who was pretty much responsible for me becoming a professional actor, giving me the encouragement and hiring me
现在跟他们并肩教学？对，对。他们现在是我的同事了，这真的很酷。太疯狂了。事实上，那个几乎可以说是让我成为一名职业演员、给我鼓励并雇用我的人，
and got me my equity card eventually, I kind of taught under him as his, that was my pitch, was like, look, you're so such a good teacher that you made this department, like a fun thing to do, so you have way too many students. So you need a helper. And basically, I'll be the, like, junior theater teacher
最终还帮我拿到了演员工会卡（Equity card），我基本上是在他手下当助教，当时我的说辞是：“听着，你是个这么优秀的老师，你把这个部门搞得这么有趣，所以你的学生实在太多了。你需要一个帮手。”基本上，如果你们愿意收留我的话，我就会成为那个，呃，初级戏剧老师，他们同意了。那是什么时候？我93年大学毕业，所以这大概是94年、94年到95年，然后我95年搬到了洛杉矶。哇。我也是。好的。哇。多么巧合。把你的眉毛放下，肖恩。
if you'll have me, and they did. And when was that? I graduated college in 93, so this would have been 94, 94, 95, and then I moved to L.A. in 95. Wow. I did too. Okay. Wow. What a coincidence. Lower your eyebrows, Sean.
操。95年有好多人来到这儿的机场。就像一天一百万个。我记得我们以前经常顶撞着去试镜，肖恩。经常这样。等一下。又倒下一个。然后我上了前面那条。
Fuck. A lot of people hit the airport in 95 out here. Like a million a day. I remember we auditioned up against each other all the time, Sean. All the time. Wait a minute. lost another one down. And then I went on the front.
405号公路。我走的是405号。什么车？你从哪个出口上来的？因为我当时在405号。好吧，等等。我来得太早了，那时候它还叫404号。谢谢。
405. I was on the 405 deal. What car? What exit did you get on? Because I was on the 405. Okay, wait. I came here so long ago it was the 404. Thank you. It's
这是一张表。好吧，等一下。等等。抱歉，乔恩，在我们巡演的时候，威利或杰森，他们中的一个提出来过。是威利。那是史上最棒的冷笑话。虽然也是最蠢的。当时你们在吃日本料理。
a sheet. Okay. Wait a minute. Wait. Sorry, John, when we were on tour, Will or Jason, one of them came up. It was Will. The best pun. In the history of puns, it was the dumbest. You were eating Japanese food.
我一直在说，我太懒得做饭了，所以我点了一些日本料理。生鱼片（Sashimi）。太蠢了。我们当时累得脑子都转不动了，笑得停不下来。哦，天哪，有那么好笑吗？我眼泪都笑出来了。我们马上回来。
I kept going, I was too lazy to make dinner, so I ordered some Japanese food. Sashimi. It's so stupid. And we were so punch drunk and tired, we couldn't stop laughing. Oh, God, was that funny? I was crying real tears. And we will be right back.
现在，回到节目中。乔恩，你有没有考虑过做一些如此慷慨、充满爱心且富有回报意义的事，比如回去，再次教授八年级的经典表演课？既然你现在，已经有了16个艾美奖。提名。这太疯狂了。那是任何人凭一部剧获得的最多的提名吗？这绝对是个纪录。我不这么认为。
And now, back to the show. John, would you ever consider doing something so generous and loving and give back-ish as going, as teaching the eighth-grade classic again? Now that you're, that you got the 16 Emmys, this incredible career. Nominations. That's crazy. Is that the most nominations anybody's ever received for one show? It's got to be a record. I don't think so.
这太疯狂了。我觉得，是因为它们有点像，它们是为，后来我成了这部剧的制片人，所以我获得了最佳……之类的提名。但你作为演员赢得了三个？我赢了一个。哦。不。为了《广告狂人》的最终季。
It's crazy. I think there's been, because they were kind of, they were for, eventually I became a producer on the show, so I got nominated for best. and things like that. But you won three as an actor? I won one. Oh. No. For the final season of Bad Men.
但我被提名过，我想，作为《周六夜现场》（SNL）和《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）以及其他一些节目的客串明星。所以我想那些都被归纳进去了。你拿那些获奖感言怎么办？你把那15篇没用上的获奖感言怎么处理了？我还留着它们。我敢打赌你留着。我把它们原封不动地记在这儿呢。
But I was nominated, I think, as a guest star on SNL and on 30 Rock and a couple of things like that. So I think those have been lumped in there. What'd you do with all the speeches? Would you do with the 15 speeches that you didn't use? I still got them. I bet you do. I still got them right up here.
不，不。你是把它们背下来了还是写下来了？不，不。我什么都没写。我从来没写过任何东西。你没有任何准备好的想法吗，万一我上台了。我想确保我不会忘记感谢……说实话，真没有。
No, no. Did you memorize them or did you write them down? No, no. I didn't write anything. I never wrote anything down ever. You didn't have any sort of thoughts prepared if I get up. I want to make sure I don't forget to thank. Honestly, no.
我真的没有。杰森，你有在你落选的那几次里把感言写下来吗？哦，对。不，我有一本书。对。你确实写下来了。对。当贝特曼获奖时，我是最早一批响应的人。
I really didn't. Did you, Jason, did you write a few of the times that you lost? Oh, yeah. No, I've got a book. Yeah. You did write them down. Yeah. I was an early adopter for when Bateman won.
我就在旁边，大概在短信群聊里排第四吧。恭喜你，老兄。乔恩真的是极其——保留。支持。爱你们。始终如一。哦，操。你知道吗？
I was right there on, probably number four on the text chain. Congrats, buddy. John is incredibly-reserve it. Supportive. Love you. Consistent. Oh, fuck. You know what?
你知道有什么好笑的吗。恭喜你，杰森。怎么了？我知道已经过去好几年了。不，你是赢得艾美奖的那个人。抱歉，我觉得我从来没说过什么。总比没有好。等等。生鱼片。
You know what's a good point. Congrats, Jason. What happened? I know it's been a couple years. No, you were winning the Emmy. Sorry, I don't think I ever said anything. It better late than that. Wait. Sashimi.
生鱼片，好吧？你知道吗？威利又可以用那个老笑话了，巡演时的另一个笑话，就是当我对杰森说，我圣诞节送了他高尔夫球，比如两套每套18个高尔夫球之类的东西。然后我说：“你收到那个了吗？”他说：“哦，对，我早就有了。”
Sashimi, all right? You know what? Will can use the same joke again, another one from the tour, which was when I said to Jason, I got him golf balls for Christmas, like two sets of 18 golf balls each or something. And I said, did you ever get that? And he goes, yeah, I already had those.
然后威利说：“这真是对‘谢谢’的一种神反转。”等等，我当时说什么来着？我早就有了？不，肖恩，你说的是你把它们弄丢了。肖恩，你说，我给了你几盒高尔夫球。你来到我家，我把它们送给你，然后你说：“哦，对了，我确实收到了。”我说：“嗯，这真是对‘谢谢’的一种有趣的扭曲。”那应该叫作“谢谢”。
And Will goes, that's a twist on thank you. Wait, what did I say? I already had those? No, Sean, you said that you dropped them. Sean, you go, I gave you like a couple boxes of golf balls. You came over to my house and I gave them to you and go, and Jason, you said, oh, yeah, yeah, I did get those. I said, well, that's a fun twist on thank you. That's pronounced, thank you.
肖恩，我觉得那事没发生。我觉得你们俩都不……回到杰森的问题。乔恩，你现在还会回去教书吗？你还有那种渴望吗？我当然会。当时有人提供机会让我把合同延长一年。我本来很乐意那么做的。
Sean, I don't think that happened. I don't think you're both. Wait back to Jason's question. Would you ever go back and teach now, John? Would you ever do that desire still there? I sure would. I was offered a chance to extend my contract by another year. And I would have loved to have done it.
但我当时24岁，快满25岁了。我想，好吧，也许我至少应该尝试去洛杉矶闯闯。看看会发生什么。然后，你知道的，我真的去了。不过我是真的很想去。我发现那非常有成就感。我不知道现在有了手机和互联网，教学会变成什么样。那是互联网和手机出现之前的年代。
But I was 24 turning 25 at the time. And I thought, well, maybe I'm at least going to try to do LA. I see what happens. And, you know, I did. And I really would, though. I found it tremendously fulfilling. I don't know what teaching is like now with phones and internet. This was pre-internet, pre-phone.
嗯，我刚才就是想问这个，就是对你来说，现在的教学会是什么样的。比如，你当时作为表演老师，与你现在将如何教表演相比，虽然我们不想陷入表演的专业细节里，免得失去我们仅有的唯一听众。但是，作为一个整体的表演理论，你现在会怎么教孩子们？会有所不同吗？可能会很相似，甚至一模一样。只是作为一个50岁的人，我比当年那个努力系着领带的24岁小伙子更有可信度了。对。你当时接的那个演出是什么？
Well, that's how I was going to kind of ask, like, what teaching would be like now for you, though. Like, you as an acting teacher then versus how you would teach acting now, not to get into acting weeds, because we'll lose our one listener. But, like, as your whole theory about acting, like, how would you teach the kids now? Would it be different? It would probably be similar, if not identical. I would just have much more credibility as a 50-year-old rather than a 24-year-old guy trying to wear a tie. Yeah. What was the gig that you had?
你在《广告狂人》之前做的工作是什么？我当时处于失业状态，大概……我试镜中了一个试播集，结果被炒了。然后在接下来的试播集季里，我又去为其他七个试播集试镜，一个都没中。我一路闯到了最后阶段，然后……七次。天哪。所以《广告狂人》是我那一季的第八次试镜。而且时间极其靠后，
What was the job you had right before Madman? I was kind of unemployed for like, I got a pilot, which I got fired off of. And then I tested for seven other pilots the following pilot season and got none. I went all the way up to the top and then. Seven times. Oh, my God. So Madman was my eighth test that season. And it was crazy late in the, in,
以前被称为试播集季的时期，因为它是 AMC 电视台出品的，他们其实并不太懂怎么搞试播集季。所以他们的日程安排跟其他所有人都不同。但我已经试镜了七次，全搞砸了。所以，是的，我的上一份工作是一个试播集，后来被改名为《老友一家亲》（Related），主演有莉兹·卡潘（Lizzy Caplan）、詹妮弗·艾斯波西托（Jennifer Esposito）以及另外一个人。我扮演的角色是……天哪，为什么我想不起她的名字了？
what used to be called pilot season because it was on AMC, which didn't really know how to do pilot season. So they just had a different schedule than everybody else. But I had tested seven times and biffed them all. So yeah, so my last job was a pilot that was called something that then went on to be called A Show Called Related with Lizzie Kaplan, Jennifer Spizito, and someone else. and I played the love interest of, God, why am I spacing on her name?
她和茱莉亚·罗伯茨一起演过《风月俏佳人》。劳拉·圣贾科莫（Laura San Giacomo）？对，劳拉·圣贾科莫。劳拉·圣贾科莫是三兄妹中的老大，我是她的爱慕对象，在这个试播集里她自杀了，她在剧里演得非常棒，但他们每天都强迫她随叫随到，而她家里还有一个孩子。这感觉就像，他们对她太残酷了。然后他们解雇了她。
She was in Pretty Woman with Julia Roberts. Sanjukomo? Yes, Laura Sanjoko. So Laura Sanjoko was the eldest of three siblings, and I was her love interest, and she killed herself on this pilot, and she was wonderful in it, and they forced her call every day, and she had a kid at home. It was like, they treated her terribly. And then they fired her.
当权者对她说：“你被开除了。”他们对我说：“但是你，我们很喜欢你，你要留下来。”我说：“没有适合我的角色了，我的爱慕对象都没了。我没有关联的对象，我也不是这个家庭的人。所以这说不通。”不，不，不，不。他们还是留下了我，一直留着、留着、留着。
And the powers that be said, you're out. And they told me, they're like, but you're, we like you and you're going to stay. I was like, there's no part for, like, that was my love interest. I don't have a person and I'm not in the family. So it doesn't make sense. No, no, no, no, no. And they kept me, kept me, kept me.
我不得不拒绝了另外几份我本可以接的工作。然后他们在最后一天解除了我的合同，把我给解雇了。所以那是《广告狂人》之前我的最后一这份工作。太棒了。现在站在另一端回看，你的视角发生了多大的改变？我们都知道我们都经历过那种阶段。光是听你描述，就几乎勾起了类似创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的感觉。哦，对，确实。
And I had to turn down another couple of jobs that now I was available for. And then they released my option on the last day and fired me. So that was my last gig before Madman. That's so great. And what a change of perspective you have now on the other end of it? And we all know we've been there. of just hearing you describe it brings almost like PTSD. Oh, yeah, for sure.
是的，就像你说的，我们都有过类似的经历。没错。哦，这个要成了。哦，没成。然后它会以一种更糟糕、绝不可能想到的方式走向失败。没错。一个很好的例子是，虽然当时感觉就像在地狱一样，但如果那部剧继续拍下去，如果他们没有解雇你，
Yeah, like you said, we've all had a version of that. Yeah, for sure. Oh, this is going to go. Oh, it didn't. And then it's going to go in the far worse way that never possibly could have. Right. And a good example of while it probably felt like hell at the time, had that show kept going, had they not fired you,
你就没法去演《广告狂人》了。所以这是一件很棒的……对，一切发生都是有原因的。所以你的意思是凡事要看光明的一面，对此，我（你知道的）表示赞同。那个杯子里还有很多水呢。乔尼，我不知在哪儿读到过，说你在《广告狂人》之后，接到了大约800个把背景设定在60年代的角色邀请，或者是那种千篇一律、一遍又一遍的相同类型。但你足够聪明，选择等待，等待那件真正的好事。
you would have been unavailable to do Mad Men. So it was a great... Yeah, everything happens. Yeah, everything happens for a reason. So you're saying look at the bright side of things, which I, you know, I'm going to say I agree with. There's plenty of fluid in that glass. Johnny, I read somewhere that you, after Mad Men, you got offered like 800 parts where it took place in the 60s or some kind of same thing over and over and over again. But you were smart enough to wait out, wait for that one good thing.
那件好事是什么？很显然，就像……一旦某个东西火了，紧接着就会有五个山寨版本接踵而至。对我们来说，NBC 推出了一部叫做《泛美航空》（Pan Am）之类的剧。对。讲的是60年代60个空姐的故事。然后又有什么关于伍德斯托克的其他版本，总之全都是这类的东西。然后，你知道的，接着电影《革命之路》（Revolution Road）上映了——所有这些60年代题材变成了某种热门商品，或者至少是60年代末期。
And what was that one thing? Well, there's obviously like, as soon as one thing hits, then there's five versions of that thing that thing that. coming out on the pike. And so for us, it was NBC came out with something like called like Pan Am. Yeah. Something that was about like 60 stewardesses in the 60s. And then like there was some other version of like Woodstock and it was just all this stuff. And, you know, then the like the movie Revolution Road came out like there were all of these kind of things that the 60s became kind of a hot commodity or at least the late 60s.
而且确实如此。不仅如此，这也是，是的，所以如果有那种抽烟喝酒很多的忧郁阴暗角色，我就会拿到那个剧本。而我当时的想法是：那是我的日常工作。我并不，我喜欢它。我能以很高的水平完成它，而且我非常感激。但那是我的日常工作。相比之下，我更想做一些完全不同的事情。
And it was. And not only that, It was just, yeah, it was like, so if there was a brooding, dark character that smoke and drank a lot, then I got that script. And I was kind of like, that's my day job. Like, I don't, and I love it. And I get to do it at a very high level, and I very much appreciate it. But it's my day job. Like, I would rather do something radically different.
你有没有哪怕一瞬间觉得：“天哪，我知道没工作是什么滋味，也许我应该直接接下其中一个角色呢？”这种本能反应，当你面临这种情况时，就是用双手紧紧抓住一切，拼死抱住。但我不知道。有什么东西，我猜我当时年纪大了。我当时36岁，37岁。所以我就觉得：“呃，好吧，我懂了。这进展得似乎挺顺利。”
Was any part of you, like, oh, God, I know what it's like to not work so much that maybe I should just take one of these things. Like, the immediate instinct, when you have that, is to just grab everything with both. hands and hold on for dear life. But I don't know. There was something, I guess I was older. I was 36 at the time, 37. Like, I was kind of like, eh, all right, I got this. This seems to be going really well.
但紧接着，你知道的，洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lorne Michaels）打来电话说：“你为什么不来主持节目呢？”我当时简直觉得：“这一定是个恶作剧。我无法理解。”然后我，好，好。事实上，他第一次邀请我时我不得不拒绝，因为我和我当时的那个女友计划了一次超级大旅行。比如，我从来没去过希腊。
But then, like, you know, Lauren Michaels came calling and said, like, why don't you host the show? And I was literally like, this has to be a prank. I don't understand. And I, yes, yes. And in fact, I had to turn it down the first time he asked because my then girlfriend at the time and I had planned this huge trip. Like, I'd never been to Greece.
我们当时已经计划好了整个两周长的假期。根本没法改期。我就想，好吧，我居然有机会对洛恩·迈克尔斯说“不”。肖恩再也不会去米科诺斯岛了。告诉他发生了什么。我知道，肖恩。发生什么了，肖恩？天哪。
We had, like, had planned this whole, like, two-week-long getaway. And it was like, we couldn't move it. And I was like, well, I get to say no to Lorne Michaels. Sean will never go to Mekino's again. Tell him what happened. I know, Sean. What happened, Sean? Jesus.
对。你太了解我了。我喜欢这些亮点。乔恩，你知道这很有趣。《广告狂人》过去是，现在依然是。一部如此令人难以置信的剧，我觉得它在很多方面真的改变了电视，
Yeah. You know me too well. I love the highlights. John, you know, it's funny. Madman was and remains. such an incredibly, like, it's one of those shows that really changed, I feel like in a lot of ways, changed TV,
改变了人们看待电视的方式，是一部拥有难以置信的精彩剧本的作品，你在里面的表现简直太棒了。我告诉你，这有一个证明你有多伟大的佐证，你当时在那个角色里表现得极其出色，现在依然如此，因为它至今仍在发光发热。当我真正开始认真观看这部剧时，
changed the way that people look at TV, was one of incredible, incredible writing, and you were so incredible in it. And I'll tell you, here's a testament to how great you are, you were in that part, and you are, because it still lives on. When I actually started watching it in earnest,
我已经认识你好几年了，然后开始看这部剧，并且完全沉浸其中，看得根本停不下来，一集不落地一直看完全部，老实说，你的唐·德 Draper（Don Draper）的表演真的深深打动了我。
I had already known you a few years, and then started watching it, and was completely immersed in it, and could not get enough of it and watched absolutely every episode all the way through to the end and was really profoundly moved by your performance as Don Draper, honestly.
真的，真的，真的，千真万确。它现在已经具有历史意义了。绝对的。这有没有改变你平时跟乔恩相处时的态度？没有，没有，但……当然有。不过我觉得……变得更加恭敬了。
And really, really, really, truly. It's historical now. Absolutely. Did it change the way you acted around John when you'd hang out with him afterwards? No, no, but yes, of course. But I think... Way more deferential.
变得多多了。来看看乔恩怎么说。他是我的朋友，我的朋友乔恩。我的朋友乔恩是。乔恩，你想要点什么吗？我是说，我本不打算出门的，但我可以。我完全可以出门。孩子们已经上床睡觉了，门也锁上了，但我会起身的。
Way more. Let's see what John has to say. He's my friend, my friend John. My friend John is. John, do you want anything? I mean, I wasn't going out, but I will. I will totally go out. The kids are in bed and the doors are locked, but I'll get up.
不，我会穿好衣服的。我会穿好衣服的。但是，所以你做了这样一件事，它在很多方面改变了你的生活。绝对的。而且起初可能挺吓人的，也挺奇怪的。就像你说的，洛恩·迈克尔斯打电话找你。而且这一切并不是在你18岁的时候发生的。对。
No, I'll get dressed. I'll get dressed. But did, so you do something like that, that changes your life in so many ways. Absolutely. And it's at first scary, probably, and weird. Like you say, Lauren Michaels is calling you. And it didn't happen at 18 years old. Yeah.
直到今天，你知道的，杰森，天哪，你的人生和你的成长经历，让你从小六岁起就成了名人。我记得你演过《银匙》（Silver Spoons），我直说了吧。对。我是说，我是个粉丝。我早期就是个粉丝。我觉得这小孩挺厉害的。我懂。
To this day, you know, Jason God, your life and growing up the way you grew up being famous since you were six. I remember you on Silver Spoons, I'll say it. Yeah. I mean, I was a fan. I was a fan early on. I was like, this kid's good. I get it.
但是，是的，这改变了一切，你知道的。它确实提供了令人难以置信的大量机会，但也伴随着大量，你知道的，警示，就像，在很多方面，小心你许下的愿望。所以，你知道的，我们也是，我们也是在那个时期，这部剧真正开始出名，而我大概在2007年左右也开始出名了，这听起来好像没那么久远，但其实是很久以前的事了，不仅因为那是15年前，而且那正是他们推出 iPhone 的那一年。我想大概也是在这个时候，Twitter（推特）
But, yeah, it changes everything, you know. And it really does provide an incredible amount of opportunity, but it comes with an incredible amount of, like, you know, a caveat, you know, like, just be careful what you wish for in a lot of ways. So, you know, we also, we also came around, you know, the show really kind of got famous, and I then got famous around 2007, which seems like not that long ago, but was a long time ago, not only it was 15 years ago, but it was, that was the year they came out with the iPhone. And I think it was maybe around the time that Twitter,
诞生了。然后大约在2010年有了 Instagram，所有这些东西开始涌现，人们接触互联网的方式变成了装在口袋里并且全天候24小时在线。所以博客复盘文化也就是从那个时候开始兴起的。因此，这种能够实时讨论剧集的积极参与的粉丝群体，恰好在我们成名的时候出现了。所以我们的剧能取得成功，里面有很多机缘巧合和运气的成分。这太疯狂了，像一阵旋风，而且让人忍不住去享受它，因为它确实很有趣。像这样你参与其中并且获得成功的情况真的很少发生，我们大家都至少经历过一次。在某些情况下，有过好几次这样的爆款，你完全无法掌控，只能顺其自然，享受这段旅程。
started. And then like 2010 was Instagram and like all of these things were starting to kind of like people's access to the internet became in their pocket and 24-7. And so that was kind of the blogging recap culture was just starting. So this idea of kind of actively engaged fans that could in real time kind of talk about the shows really came around right when we happened to get famous. So there was a lot of like serendipity and luck. involved in our show's success. And it was, you know, it was crazy. And it was a whirlwind and it was impossible to kind of not enjoy because it was enjoyable. And it's so rarely happens that you, and we've all been a part of at least one. In some cases, several hits like that where you just, it's out of your control and you just have to hold on for the ride.
而在你现在的年龄，在这一行里获得这种名气、尊重和成功，我认为是幸运的，因为你已经具备了应对这种局面的心理应对机制。你是否能够从名气中汲取一些真正有益的部分，并以健康的方式融入你的生活？是的，我的意思是，部分原因在于学会接受并欣赏它，如果这说得通的话。
And that's kind of what it did. But getting that level of fame and respect. and success in a profession at the age you are at is fortuitous, I would think, in that you've got the coping mechanisms to deal with something like that. Were you able to take some really beneficial parts from fame and incorporated into your life in a healthy way? Yeah, I mean, I think part of it is being okay with, with appreciating it, if that makes any sense.
对，对。我想我们当中有很多人想要对它嗤之以鼻、轻描淡写，并保持谦逊，这也是非常健康和好的。但我觉得，坦然地说出“你知道吗？没错，我干得好。太棒了！
Yeah, yeah. There's a lot of us, I think, that want to like poo-poo it and play it down and be modest with it, which is also very healthy and good. But there's something very, I think, healthy about saying, like, you know what? Yeah, good for me. Hooray.
太好了，我！”这其实是一件非常健康的事。我并不是白白干了10年，却几乎得不到什么认可、赞誉、金钱或工作，或者类似这样的事情……你知道的，当我95年来到洛杉矶时，我和肖恩是1995年抵达的，我花了三年时间才找到一份工作。所以，你知道的，这绝不是因为我不够努力。我什么都去试镜。
Yeah, me. I didn't, for nothing, like, work for 10 years with very little recognition or accolades or money or jobs. or anything like, you know, when I landed in 95, when Sean and I landed in 1995, it took me three years to even get a job. So, you know, and it wasn't for lack of trying. I auditioned for everything.
你知道的，我那次奇怪的试镜经历是为米米·莱德（Mimi Leder）的《天地大冲撞》（Deep Impact）试镜，这个角色后来落在了乔恩·费儒（John Favro）头上。对。而且，你知道的，直到今天我仍然想说，我还是有点生他们的气。当然。生他的气。当然。
You know, my weird audition story was auditioning for Mimi Leader for Deep Impact, a part that eventually went to John Favro. Yeah. And, you know, who to this day I still say, I'm still a little angry at them. Sure. angry at him. Sure.
因为他抢了我的角色。他当时有《全职浪子》（Swingers）。他是个编剧。他已经拥有一切了。他难道不能……他不需要《天地大冲撞》
For beat me out for that. He had swingers. He had swingers. He's a writer. He had so much. And he couldn't... He didn't need deep impact. He couldn't back off
退一步把那个角色让给我吗？我当时真的很需要。不。他现在可以报答你了。给你在《曼达洛人》（Mandalorian）里安排个甜蜜的戏份。来点曼达洛人的爱。没错。一段非常紧凑的三场戏的戏份。
and just give me that. I needed it. No. He could pay you back now. Give you some nice sweet arc on Mandalorian. Some Mandalorian love. Yeah. Nice little tight little three-up, three-up arc.
好吧，他也是……他也是所有那些大片里的那个人，还有所有漫威电影。他不是……他是漫威的乔尼吗？拜托。他就是那个人。他不是也演了那些电影吗？
Well, he's also... He's the guy in all that stuff, too, and all the Marvel stuff. Isn't he... He's Johnny Marvel? Come on. He's the guy. Isn't he in those movies, too?
他给罗伯特·唐尼在《钢铁侠》三部曲里开过车。
He's down his driver. Right? Yes. So far. Getting his sag benefits, you know what I mean? Listen, he's driven Robert Downey in the Iron Man trilogy,
四部曲。对。他给杰克·尼科尔森开过车。没错，我觉得是。真的吗？在《尽善尽美》（As Good as It Gets）里？真的吗？我是编的吗？
Quadruplee. Yep. He's driven Jack Nicholson. Yeah, I think. Truly? In as good as it gets? Really? Am I making this up?
四倍。是的。他开车载过杰克·尼科尔森。是的，我想是的。真的吗？在《尽善尽美》里？真的吗？我是不是在瞎编？
I don't remember that? Was he a driver in that? Was he in as good as it gets? I don't know. I'll be honest. I might be conflating a lot of things. John is a fun guy to act with. Have you guys done that?
我不记得那个了？他当时在里面演司机吗？他演过《尽善尽美》吗？我不知道。老实说，我可能把很多事情搞混了。约翰是个很有趣的合作演员。你们俩跟他合作过吗？
No, but I obviously know him. He's a fun guy in general. He is fun. in a scene. Very fast, very quick. And him and Vince together, that must have been fun to watch on the side. Oh, man, yeah.
没有，但我显然认识他。他总体来说是个很有趣的人。他在片场很有趣。动作非常快，非常敏捷。他和文斯在一起，在旁边看着肯定很有意思。哦，天哪，是的。
He's, he's, I've met those guys. I live on the east side of L.A. And they're kind of credited with kind of bringing Loz Phelis into the hipster world for sure. Yeah. The Dresden, the whole kind of swing, you know,
他，他，我见过那些人。我住在洛杉矶东区。他们可以说是把洛斯费利斯带入嬉皮士世界的人，绝对是的。德累斯顿，那种摇滚风格，你知道的，
the swingers scene was their scene for sure. Right. And when those guys walked into a bar in 1996, like, you knew it. Oh, yeah. They were, They were very good hangs and they were very funny even then. And, you know, the proofs in the pudding, they both have very nice career.
那种嬉皮士风格的场景绝对是他们的地盘。没错。当那些家伙在1996年走进酒吧时，你一眼就能认出来。哦，是的。他们很会聊天，即使在当时也非常搞笑。而且，事实证明，他们俩都有非常棒的职业生涯。
We were talking the other day about, Jason and I were talking about Vince, about how fucking quick and funny he is. There's just no one better at what he does. He's unreal. Yeah. And nobody does what he does, which is a nice place to be. Yeah. And now, a word from our sponsor.
我们前几天还在谈论，杰森和我当时在谈论文斯，谈论他到底有多么敏捷和搞笑。在这一行里，没有人比他更优秀了。他简直太不真实了。是的。而且没有人能取代他，这真是一个令人羡慕的位置。没错。好了，现在插播一条赞助商广告。
All right. Back to the show. John, when you, you know, now that you worked your butt off to get to where you are and in in hindsight it probably took longer than you wanted and longer than than what you explained before um is there anything that you tell younger actors going through it now or any kind of business businessy advice rather than acting you know technique advice that you know that you would probably pass on to anybody looking to make it now you know i've talked to actually jenna fisher about this who's also from st louis so i've known for some time i didn't know we're in st louis but um i i i
好了。回到节目。约翰，当你，你知道的，现在你付出了艰辛的努力才达到了今天的成就，回想起来，这可能比你想要的要花更长时间，也比你之前解释的时间要长，呃，对于现在正在经历这一切的年轻演员，你有什么想对他们说的吗？或者有什么关于业务方面的建议，而不是表演（你知道的，技巧方面的建议），你可能会传授给任何现在想要成功的人？你知道的，其实我跟珍娜·费舍尔聊过这个，她也是圣路易斯人，所以我认识她有一段时间了。我不知道我们在圣路易斯，但是，呃，我，我，我
We were talking about something for some reason. And it's funny, like, you can go to all of the acting schools in the world, and nobody really teaches you about the business of acting. Right. And what it really is like, of course, like managing your day and managing your time. And your expectations. Your expectations for sure, like thinking about, you know, here's what it is to, like, drive into the valley in August
我们不知为何在聊某件事。有趣的是，你可以上遍全世界所有的表演学校，但没有人真正教你表演这门生意。没错。它真正的样子是什么，当然，比如如何管理你的每一天，如何管理你的时间。还有你的期望。你的期望肯定也是其中之一，比如想象一下，你知道的，八月开车去山谷是什么感觉，
and then have another audition in Fox in an hour, you know, and it's, you know, it's a lot, and it's real, and it's actually the part of acting that most actors engage with, from a professional standpoint, far more than they do, you know, scene study or whatever. And so there's that part, and there's also just the fact that everything at this level moves so quickly, especially in television,
然后一个小时后在福克斯电视台还有另一场试镜，你知道的，这真的很不容易，而且很现实，实际上这也是大多数演员从职业角度来看，参与最多的表演部分，远远超过了他们（你知道的）剧本研究或其他什么。所以有这部分，还有这样一个事实，就是在这个层面的所有事情进展都太快了，尤其是在电视行业，
that if you're not ready to go, if you haven't done the work before you get to work, then you're, it's not going to go. well for one reason or another. And I've seen it happen. I've been a victim of it of just like, oh, I'll just wing it, and then you're like, uh-oh. Right.
如果你没有准备好开工，如果你在开工前没有做好功课，那么你，事情就不会顺利，总有这样或那样的原因。我见过这种情况发生。我也曾是受害者，心里想着，哦，我会临场发挥的，然后你就会想，呃-oh。没错。
But it's a real lesson to learn of just, you know, it's the first one I learned in class is just like, be prepared. I had an acting teacher too years ago. He kind of would profess this, and he was kind of a working actor. He was a character-actory guy, and he'd lived in L.A. a long time. He had moved back in New York.
但这真的是一个必须吸取的教训，你知道的，这是我在课堂上学到的第一课，那就是：做好准备。多年前我也有过一个表演老师。他经常这样宣明，他是一个真正的职业演员。他是一个性格演员，在洛杉矶住了很久。后来他又搬回了纽约。
It's like early... Charles Nelson Riley? Early 90s. Charles Bronson It was Charles Bronson It was And we'd only do scenes From Fort Apache the Bronx
就像早期的……查尔斯·纳尔逊·赖利？90年代初。查尔斯·布朗森 是查尔斯·布朗森 是的 我们只排练 电影《布朗克斯的故事》里的片段
But he would Great movie He wasn't in that Charles Bronson was Sure he was So anyway You had a lot to pick for him But I'm glad you picked that one
但他会 伟大的电影 他不在那部里 查尔斯·布朗森在里面 他当然在 所以无论如何 你有很多关于他的选择 但我很高兴你选了那个
Yeah me too He would say the same thing Which was like as a young actor If you get to set And you start going like I'm going to work through my stuff, you're fired. There's no time to work through your shit.
是的，我也是 他会说同样的话 也就是作为年轻演员 如果你到了片场 开始说“我要琢磨一下我的戏”，你就被解雇了。没有时间让你去琢磨那些破事。
They got to get this shot and they got to move on. And they don't give a fuck about what your process is and how you get there. You deliver. When they fucking call action, be ready. And I think that that was like the, I had that in early age. And I felt lucky because I feel a lot of actors feel like,
他们必须拍完这个镜头然后继续前进。他们才不在乎你的创作过程是什么样的，你是怎么进入状态的。你得拿出成果。当他们他妈的喊“Action”时，给老子准备好。我觉得这就是，我年轻的时候就懂这个道理。我觉得自己很幸运，因为我觉得很多演员觉得，
I'm just going to go. And I'm going to work it out. I'm just going to feel it. Once they see how amazing I am, they'll give me all the time in the world. Right. But it depends on what you want, right? If you want to be like, take Tom Cruise, for example.
我这就去。然后我会临场发挥。我只要凭感觉来。等他们看到我有多厉害，他们就会给我全世界所有的无限时间。没错。但这也取决于你想要什么，对吧？如果你想成为——以汤姆·克鲁斯为例。
People are like, they didn't just hand it to him. Like he worked his butt off to be Tom Cruise. You know what I mean? And having worked with him, he is the first guy on set. He's in the gym at 5 in the morning, call times at 6, he's there, he's ready to go, and he's the last guy that leaves. And it's that guy deserves it. You know, he wants it, he got it, he works hard at it.
人们觉得，机会不是白白送到他手里的。为了成为汤姆·克鲁斯，他付出了巨大的努力。你知道我的意思吗？和她合作过之后，我发现他是片场第一个到的人。他早上5点就在健身房锻炼，通告时间是6点，他就在那儿，随时准备开工，而且他是最后一个离开的人。这样的人才配得上成功。你知道的，他渴望成功，他得到了成功，为此付出了艰苦的努力。
And that's, you know, Jason, I know you've directed. Have you guys both directed television, Sean and Will? Like, it's the same thing when you sit through those auditions and you think like, all right, the guy that comes, who's going to come in and take this part? Who's going to come in? So I can worry about something else. So I can worry about something else.
这就是，你知道的，杰森，我知道你导演过。肖恩和威尔，你们两个都导演过电视剧吗？就像你坐在那里看试镜时的情景一样，你会想：好吧，谁会来接演这个角色？谁会来？这样我就可以去操心别的事了。这样我就可以去操心别的事了。
And by the way, so I can go back to the set. I got to shoot. Yeah. And you watch the guys that do it that walk in and just say like, I don't have any questions or I don't have any ridiculous questions. Not how you, hey, there's not 10 minutes of bullshit. No. It's like, let's do this.
顺便说一句，这样我就可以回片场了。我还得拍戏呢。是的。然后你会看着那些走进来的人，他们会说：我没有任何问题，也没有那些荒谬的问题。不是那种，嘿，没有十分钟的废话。没有。而是说：我们开始吧，
and I'm going to prove to you how I can crush this. And then it's like, great. That's the guy I want on the day when I'm 10 hours behind. Sean, you do. But you haven't directed, but you also, you go to the, when it goes to going to the gym, you're the last guy there and the first guy out, right? Yeah.
我要向你证明我是怎么完美驾驭这个角色的。然后就会觉得：太棒了。这正是我在落后10个小时进度时想要找的人。肖恩，你确实。虽然你没当过导演，但你也一样，去健身房的时候，你是最后一个到、第一个走的人，对吧？是的。
Very similar. Yeah, I mean, look at me. So, John, growing up in St. Louis, did you spend any summers at the Lake of the Ozarks down there? Yeah. In fact, a good portion of my family has retired down there. My dad's sister, my Betty, lives down there full time now. Is it true that there's a bar down there that does real well called Big Dix halfway in?
非常相似。是的，你看我这样。所以，约翰，你在圣路易斯长大，有没有去那里的奥沙克湖度过夏天？有。事实上，我很大一部分亲戚都在那里退休了。我爸的妹妹，我姑妈贝蒂，现在全职住在那里。真的像传闻中那样，那里有一家生意非常火爆的酒吧，开在半山腰，名字叫“大鸡巴”（Big Dicks）吗？
No way. Is that a true story? It's entirely possible. If I'm judging by the amount of and the quality of puns that I've seen and heard throughout the years in the Lake of the Ozarks, the Redneck Review. Is that true, Jason? Is that a real bar? That's a real bar, from what I understand, and it is a very high-level pun. That is, uh, that they deserve to do a lot of business in that.
开玩笑吧。这是真的吗？完全有可能。如果根据我在奥沙克湖多年来看过和听过的双关语的数量和质量来判断的话，《红脖子评论》。是真的吗，杰森？那是家真正的酒吧吗？据我所知，那确实是一家真酒吧，而且那是一个非常高水平的双关语。那是，呃，他们绝对配得上在那儿赚大钱。
Jason, can we get, can we get a little something out of Marty Bird? I, I don't, I don't, I don't change at all. This is a full Marty right now. We hear a little something out of Marty Bird. This is a little interview has been conducted by Marty Bird, I think. We'd love to have a conversation with Marty Bird real quick. I think it might go a little something like this. Now, did you ever see any, uh, any, uh, uh,
杰森，我们能从玛蒂·伯德身上学到点什么吗？我，我，我一点都没变。我现在的状态就是一个百分之百的玛蒂。我们能听听玛蒂·伯德的语气吗？这是一小段由玛蒂·伯德主持的采访，我想是的。我们很想跟玛蒂·伯德简单聊聊。我觉得大概会是这个样子。那么，你有没有见过任何，呃，任何，呃，呃，
Any money laundering or killings or anything down there? Very little, if any. We're painting a pretty bleak picture of the lake down there. There was a lot of bass fishing, a lot of water skiing. Yeah. And some pretty heavy drinking. Yeah. But a lot of very poor water safety.
任何洗钱、谋杀或者类似的事情吗？几乎没有，如果有的话。我们把那里的湖泊描绘成了一幅相当阴暗的画面。其实有很多鲈鱼垂钓，还有很多水上滑雪。是的。还有一些相当猛烈的酗酒。是的。但水上安全意识非常差。
But you're not getting a murder a week down there. No. Yeah. We're taking a little license. You know, fall out of the boat, hit your head. son of a bitch. I had my phone in my pocket. God damn it.
不过你在那儿并不会每周都遇到谋杀案。没有。是的。我们稍微发挥了一点艺术加工。你知道的，从船上掉下来，撞到头。他妈的。我的手机还在口袋里。真该死。
A lot of that, for sure. A lot of anger with that. But not a lot of cartel guys walking down dirt roads with shotguns in the middle of the night, right? You just didn't see it. And that doesn't mean it didn't exist. Now, are they upset at us
这种事确实挺多的。对此也充满了愤怒。但不会有很多贩毒集团的人在半夜拿着猎枪走在土路上，对吧？你根本看不见。这并不意味着它不存在。那么，他们会对我们感到不满吗？
for painting that type of a picture? I think any publicity for the Ozarks is good publicity at this point. You know, they do need to lengthen the runway there so they could get some commercial flights in there and really open up tourism, darn it? speaking, you're preaching to the choir at this point. Why don't you get down there and kind of ramrod something like that?
因为我们把他们描绘成那样？我觉得对于奥沙克湖来说，任何宣传现在都是好宣传。你知道，他们确实需要延长那里的跑道，这样才能开通一些商业航班，真正促进旅游业的发展，该死！从某种意义上说，你现在是在对牛弹琴。你为什么不亲自去那里，直接把这事给拍板推进呢？
Is that one of the other bars? The ramrod something like that? The ramrod does great business, but it's mostly on weekends. And it's gay. I'm sorry. Most of the weekends? Thank you. Johnny, what's your favorite best movie experience on a set or part that you played
那是另一家酒吧吗？搞定那种事的酒吧？搞定生意的这家酒吧生意很好，但主要是在周末。而且是个同性恋酒吧。抱歉。主要是在周末？谢谢。约翰，你在片场最喜欢的电影经历是什么？或者是你演过的哪个角色和
and experience? I will tell you. I've got it right here. He's loaded with that one. I worked on a movie called Bad Times at the El Royale a couple years ago. directed by a guy who I've known for a long time. He used to write promos for the WB. I auditioned to be the guy that reads the pro.
经历？我来告诉你。我都记在这儿呢。他太懂这个了。我几年前拍过一部电影叫《皇家酒店谋杀案》。导演是一个我认识很久的人。他以前专门为WB电视台写宣传片。我当时去试镜那个读宣传片的人。
Next on the WB. That guy that Will probably got. No, I did CBS at that time. Fair enough, fair enough. And so, and I got the offer for it during Sundance. Yeah. Came through. They said, you got 48 hours to read this.
接下来是WB。就是那个威尔可能得到的角色。不，我那时候在CBS。也对，也对。然后，我在圣丹斯电影节期间收到了这个角色的邀约。是的。消息传来了。他们说：你只有48小时的时间看剧本。
It's yours if you want it. You got to be on a plane from Sundance to Vancouver. Let me know. And I read it and I loved it. And I was like, cool, cool, cool. This is amazing. Who fell out, basically. Because clearly somebody did.
如果你想要，这就是你的。你得坐飞机从圣丹斯赶往温哥华。告诉我你的决定。我读了剧本，非常喜欢。我就觉得：太酷了，太酷了，太酷了。这太棒了。到底是谁不演了呢？因为显然有人退出了。
No, John. No, somebody did. It was fine. It was Russell Crow. Whatever. Good replacement, I think. Sure. And it was to work with Jeff Bridges,
不，约翰。不，有人退出了。没关系。那是罗素·克劳。随便啦。我觉得是个不错的替代者。当然。那是和杰夫·布里吉斯合作，
who I wanted to work with my entire life. And I've always thought was maybe the coolest. Coolest guy. You know, even pre Big Lobowski, I was just, I was on board. That's no letdown, right? He's a real, that's a high-level profession. And so I got to work with that guy for, they shot the whole thing chronologically.
我这辈子都想跟他合作。我一直觉得他可能是最酷的。最酷的家伙。你知道的，甚至在《谋杀绿脚趾》之前，我就已经是他的粉丝了。这绝对不是让人失望，对吧？他是一个真正的，那是一个高水平的职业演员。所以我有幸跟那个家伙合作了，他们整部电影都是按时间顺序拍摄的。
Spoiler alert, I die in the first act, but I shot all, you know, whatever, two and a half weeks of my part, and it was mostly with Jeff. And, man, that was a, that was, and it was a beautiful set. It was super cool. Everybody on it was nice.
剧透预警，我在第一幕就领盒饭了，但我拍完了所有的，你知道的，大概两个半星期的戏份，而且大部分都是跟杰夫一起拍的。天哪，那真是一段，而且那是一个非常漂亮的片场。简直酷毙了。片场每个人都很好。
It was, that was one of the good ones. That was really one of the good ones. John, how weird. So you actually, you did this, movie with a guy who was writing promos at the CW. What a trip for you guys, right? Did you guys acknowledge that? And I knew him through like a little poker league that we played in.
那是相当棒的经历之一。那真的是非常棒的经历之一。约翰，太不可思议了。所以你实际上，你拍了这部电影，合作的对象是一个曾在CW电视台写宣传片的人。对你们来说真是奇妙的经历，对吧？你们当时聊过这个吗？我是通过我们一起打的一个小型扑克联赛认识他的。
Like he was just, he hit the big time. Drew Goddard and he's still making movies. Oh, yeah. He's doing very well. Oh, wait, I know Drew because he's, Caroline Williams, he's married to Caroline Williams, who's a tremendous comedy writer. She's one of the funniest writers I've ever worked with. There he had. She wrote on BoJack.
就像他突然大红大紫了一样。德鲁·戈达德，他现在还在拍电影。哦，是的。他现在发展得非常好。哦，等等，我认识德鲁，因为他是，卡罗琳·威廉姆斯，他娶了卡罗琳·威廉姆斯，她是一位极其出色的喜剧编剧。她是我合作过的最搞笑的编剧之一。他确实娶了她。她曾为《马男波杰克》写过剧本。
Things happen to good people sometimes. Yeah. Now, you mentioned audition. to be the voice of CW. So the voice, the voice has been something that you've been using for a while than it sounds like, but you've really hit the top of the mountain there
好人有时也会有好报。是的。现在，你提到去试镜成为CW的专属配音。所以这个声音，这个声音听起来你已经用了一段时间了，但你真的登上了事业的巅峰，
with Mercedes for how many years now? I think going on 13 now. John Hamm. That's so cool. Yeah. Yeah, they've outlasted several CEOs and CMOs. 13 years, that's pretty good. It's not bad.
给梅赛德斯代言多少年了？我想要迎来第13个年头了。约翰·哈姆。太酷了。是的。是的，他们已经熬过了好几任CEO和CMO。13年，这相当不错了。还算不错。
Here he comes. Here he comes. It's not professional grade, though. I mean, 13 years is good, but it's not professional grade. professional. It's not professional. It doesn't matter.
他来了。他来了。不过这可达不到专业水平。我是说，13年是很不错，但还算不上专业水准。专业的。这不是专业的。这不重要。
Oh, no. I think people want to know. I will say, for the listeners out there, every now and again, I will get texts from both Jason and Will about some voiceover, something or other, which is, it's a compliment,
哦，不。我想大家都很想知道。我得说，对于听众朋友们来说，时不时地，我就会收到杰森和威尔发来的关于某些配音工作的短信，这其实是一个赞美，
but it's a left-handed compliment. No. It's always a, oh, I see you doing that too. Good for you. Good for you. Good for you. Real happy for you. Let me tell you what else is a good,
但这是一种拐弯抹角的赞美。不。这总是带着一种，哦，我看到你也在干这个。真为你高兴。真为你高兴。真为你高兴。为你感到由衷的高兴。让我告诉你什么是真正的好东西，
that Apple commercial that you do is killer. I love that. That's well done. Come on. That's beautiful. Who shot that, by the way? I want DP on director. Another guy I've known for a long, long time through our mutual friend,
你拍的那个苹果广告太棒了。我太喜欢了。拍得真好。拜托。拍得太美了。顺便问一下，那是谁拍的？我想找那个摄影指导和导演。又是一个我通过共同的朋友认识了很长很长一段时间的人，
Tall John Schrader, a guy named Wayne McClamey, who now is another guy that came out of the trenches at the WB. No way. Do you know who shot it? Do you know who the DP was? I don't remember the name of the DP, I'm sorry.
老朋友约翰·施雷德，一个叫韦恩·麦克拉米的人，他现在也是另一个从WB电视台底层杀出来的人。不会吧。你知道是谁拍的吗？你知道摄影指导是谁吗？我不记得那个摄影指导的名字了，真抱歉。
Okay, wait, Johnny, before we let you go, because I know you got to go, I want to know what you're excited about coming up. That's really getting you going. I'll tell you exactly. what I'm excited about because I've said it about four times today. I get to go to Europe for my birthday. I turned 50 last year and it was during a pandemic
好吧，等等，约翰，在我们让你离开之前，因为我知道你还有事要忙，我想知道你接下来对什么事情感到兴奋？有什么事能真正让你充满激情。我来告诉你我到底对什么感到兴奋，因为我今天大概已经说过四遍了。我终于可以去欧洲过生日了。我去年满50岁，那时正处于大流行期间，
and my big celebration was having some people over and standing 10 feet away from them. And I get to go, my gal and I get to go to the Alps for two weeks for my birthday. I've never been. I've never been to Switzerland. That's exciting. that part of France, and I've never been to that part of Italy. So we're going to do it right.
我所谓的盛大庆祝活动就是请几个人来家里，然后跟他们保持10英尺的距离。这一次我和我的女朋友终于可以去阿尔卑斯山待两个星期来庆祝我的生日。我从没去过。我从来没去过瑞士。这太令人兴奋了。还有法国的那部分，我也从来没去过意大利的那部分。所以我们要好好享受这次旅行。
You're going to like that a lot. I'm leaving in a week, and I'm very, very excited about that. That's so exciting. George can toss you the keys for the house in Como. G-C. baby, you got Como handy? Let me rock it out. It's right there. I promise I'll mop up.
你会非常喜欢那里的。我一个星期后就要出发了，对此我感到非常非常兴奋。太让人兴奋了。乔治可以把科莫湖那栋房子的钥匙扔给你。G-C，宝贝，你手里有科莫湖的房子吗？让我去享受一下。就在那里。我保证我会打扫干净的。
Why not? And listen, you can pop down to Zermat and, you know, where are you going to Switzerland? Switzerland, Stad. Stad, yes. I just want to be like, I want to do like one thing, James Bond did. Right. I want to eat dinner in a, like,
为什么不呢？听着，你可以顺便去一趟采尔马特，然后，你知道的，你要去瑞士哪里？瑞士的格施塔德。格施塔德，是的。我只想，我想做一件詹姆斯·邦德做过的事。没错。我想在一个地方吃晚饭，比如，
UFO-shaped thing that you have to take a gondola to and then you ski out dessert. Hey, are you going to get into Germany at all? You should get to Germany and have Mercedes give you one of their cars and drive on the Audubon where there's no speed limit.
像那种飞碟形状的餐厅，你必须坐缆车才能上去，然后吃完甜点直接滑雪下山。嘿，你会去德国吗？你应该去德国让梅赛德斯给你提供一辆车，然后在没有速度限制的德国高速公路上飙车。
It's incredible. I think that's a different trip, but yes, that's going to happen at some point. I'll go on that one with you. Okay. Let's go. Yeah. Come on. God, that sounds like force. Let's take, let's take this podcast. on the road and do it German style. But one more thing, and I know the personal life
这太不可思议了。我觉得那是另一趟旅程，不过是的，以后总会实现的。我跟你一起去那趟。好的。我们走吧。耶。拜托，听起来太棒了。让我们把这个播客带到路上，以德国的方式录制吧。不过还有一件事，我知道私生活比我们为谋生而做的任何事情都重要得多，但我只是为你和你的才华感到兴奋，你有没有什么即将推出的、让你感到兴奋并可以与我们分享的作品？
is way more important than anything we do for a living, but I'm just excited about you and your talent, and is there anything that you're excited that's coming up that you can share with us that you're working on or going to work on? The most exciting thing that I have coming out, which will finally come out in May, is the long-awaited 30 years on sequel to Top Gun.
我即将推出的最激动人心的作品——终于将在五月上映——就是备受期待的《壮志凌云》30年后的续集。
Oh, nice. You're in that? Yes, I am. That's great. That's coming out, I think Memorial Day. weekend around there and it's i've seen it it's really really good um it's exactly what you want out of this and it's uh i cannot wait for people to see it it was one of those things where another kind of pinch me moment like just like wait they're asking me to be in the top guns people
哦，太棒了。你参演了？是的，我演了。太棒了。那部电影大概会在阵亡将士纪念日周末前后上映，我已经看过了，真的非常非常棒。它完全满足你对这部电影的一切期待，我简直等不及让大家看到了。当时的感觉就像是另一个“掐我一下”的时刻，就像是：等等，他们竟然邀请我出演《壮志凌云》？人们
like tell my tell my 15 year old self that and right yeah i would punch my 15 year old self in the face like yeah that's healthy so tom cruise was uh not not a disappointment either i'll bet right just incredible He's the best in the biz, man. He's the best in the biz. He's as advertised. He is intense and hardworking, but that's exactly who you want. That's what you want in a Tom Cruise. Oh, yeah. That's great. I'll do a whole hour on that. That's awesome.
会对我的15岁自己说，真的吗？我大概会狠狠给15岁的自己一拳。没错，这很健康。所以汤姆·克鲁斯也没有让人失望，我敢打赌对吧？简直不可思议。他是这一行里最棒的，伙计。他是这一行里最棒的。他正如广告宣传的那样。他既狂热又努力，但这正是你想要的。这正是你对汤姆·克鲁斯的期望。哦，是的。太棒了。我可以就这个聊整整一小时。这太棒了。
Well, I'm excited about that. Johnny, thank you for being here. I know you got to run. It means the world to us, and thank you for saying yes to coming on. I'm such a big fan. Thank you very much for having me. It's rare that I know all three podcast hosts at the same time. Hopefully if Major League Baseball gets her act together, we can go out there and spend some quality time.
好吧，我对此感到非常兴奋。约翰，谢谢你来到这里。我知道你得赶时间。这对我们意义重大，非常感谢你答应来参加节目。我是你的超级粉丝。非常感谢邀请我。我很少能同时认识所有的三个播客主持人。希望如果美国职业棒球大联盟能把他们的事情理清，我们就能去那里度过一段美好的时光。
You know, Jason and I have a lovely, friendly Cardinals Dodgers rivalry that the Dodgers have had the better of the last few years. Not really, barely. You still have Flaherty, though, you know? Listen, you got the ring. You give me him and all's forgiven. Okay, I'll trade you for Walker Bueller.
你知道的，杰森和我之间有一种可爱而友好的红雀队与道奇队的竞争关系，在过去几年里道奇队一直占上风。其实也没有，勉强算吧。不过你们还有弗laherty，你知道的？听着，你们拿了总冠军。你把他让给我，以前的事就一笔勾消了。好吧，我用沃克·比勒跟你换。
Give me with the high school out here. No, no, no, no. He needs to be with Walker. Anyway, we'll talk. We'll negotiate something. No, no, no, please continue on with. fucking baseball, man. All the fucking sports. Yeah, let's end on baseball. We can end on the fact that I went on a blind date
把我们这儿的高中生给我。不，不，不，不。他必须留在沃克身边。不管怎样，我们再聊。我们会协商点什么的。不，不，不，请继续说。该死的棒球，伙计。所有该死的运动。好吧，那就以棒球结束吧。我们可以以我和杰森现在的妻子进行了一次盲约来结束
with Jason's now wife. We can all, but that's for another. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. No, he's got to go. He's got to go. I gotta go. That's the thing is in the next episode. Did you really go on a blind date with Amanda?
我们可以，但那是另一回事。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。不，他得走了。他得走了。我得走了。下一集再说这个。你真的跟阿曼达去约会过吗？
Ham, just wink at me. One wink means yes, two means. Okay, yes. John. All right, John, Ham, thank you so much, John. Thank you, Johnny. Oh, great to have you. Ham, you're the best.
哈姆，对眨个眼。眨一下代表是，两个代表。好吧，是。约翰。好吧，约翰·哈姆，非常感谢你，约翰。谢谢你，约翰。哦，很高兴你能来。哈姆，你最棒了。
You're the best. Go Burroughs. Let's bring you to land on the next time. All right, I love you guys. I love you, so. You, buddy. Bye, man. Thank you.
你太棒了。伯勒斯加油。下次再来连线。好了，我爱你们。我也爱你们。再见，伙计。拜，伙计。谢谢。
Thank you. Hi. John Ham is no ham. John is a very humble, classy, solid individual. Solid individual. Yeah. Yeah, I was super excited that he was coming on.
谢谢。嗨。约翰·哈姆可一点都不假。约翰是一个非常谦逊、有品位、踏实的人。踏实的人。是的。是的，他能来我超级兴奋。
I mean, he's like one of those guys that's, you know, I say it all the time, but about other people, but whenever he's in something, you're like, oh, this is going to be great. Yeah. Yep, he's got a real solid presence. And I really meant it about, about madmen watching that,
我的意思是，他就像那种人，你知道的，我经常这么说别人，但只要他参演了什么作品，你就会想：哦，这肯定很棒。是的。是的，他有一种非常扎实的存在感。我是认真的，关于看《广告狂人》那些话，
and truthfully, like, thinking, like, kind of know him and, like, how's this going to be watching him in this? It's kind of like, Jason, watching you and Ozark, which is also a testament to how good you are. He's like, you get into it, and you're like, you forget that you know the guy, which is, it's a higher bar to have to, a higher special time to get over. I know.
老实说，就会觉得，有点了解他，然后会想：看他在里面的表演会是什么感觉？这有点像，杰森，看你演《黑钱胜地》一样，这也是对你演技有多好的一种证明。你会全身心投入其中，然后你会忘记你其实认识这个人，这其实是一个更高的门槛，需要跨越一个更高特殊的阶段。我懂。
That's so true. And that shows how good it is. Jay, whenever I, you're, Yeah, whenever I watch it, it's like, I don't, it's transformative, as they say. So congratulations on that. Congratulations to John Hammond being so. So, Sean, also, what a great guest. So great having John on.
确实如此。这证明了它有多优秀。杰伊，每当我看到你，你，是的，每当我看到它时，就觉得，正如他们所说，这是颠覆性的。所以为此向你祝贺。祝贺约翰·哈姆表现得如此出色。那么，肖恩，这也是个绝佳的嘉宾。有约翰来作客真是太棒了。
Yeah, he's got a new podcast. Yeah, I was going to say that. Does he have a new podcast? Yeah, he's got a new podcast. It's called American Hostage, and it's on Amazon Wondry. It's fantastic. You got to listen to the trailer. The trailer sounds like an actual movie.
对，他有一个新播客。对，我正要说这个。他有新播客吗？对，他有一个新播客。叫《美国人质》，在亚马逊的Wondry上。太棒了。你们一定要听听预告片。预告片听起来就像一部真正的电影。
It's really, really cool. Ah, he's perfect for that. It's really great. He's perfect for that because he's so good. I meant it when I said, like, I watch Mad Men. And, I mean, how many, you would never think that a series about a pot store would last for how many seasons? Oh, no, no, you're thinking of, sorry, you're thinking of Med Men, which is a pot store out here in California. No, it's a different, it's a totally different, yeah.
真的很酷很酷。啊，他太适合这个了。真的很棒。他太适合这个了，因为他太优秀了。我没说错，就像我说的，我看《广告狂人》。我的意思是，多少个，你绝不会想到一部关于大麻店的剧集能拍多少季？哦，不，不，你想的是，抱歉，你想的是《梅德曼》（Med Men），那是加州这里的一家大麻店。不，那是另一个，完全是另一个，是的。
I mean, it's a very honest. Oh, sorry, Madden. So it's an anger management, like a help group. Again, it's just, honestly, I wish you could, is just kind of the play on Madison Avenue, guys of advertising. Oh. Is that kidding? Oh, yeah. Oh, I do.
我是说，这是一个非常诚实的。哦，抱歉，麦德曼（Madden）。所以这是一个愤怒管理，类似于互助小组。再说一次，这只是，老实说，我希望你能，这只是玩了一个双关语，指的是麦迪逊大道上的广告从业人员。哦。是在开玩笑吗？哦，是的。哦，我懂了。
I must. But it's like where they, you know, those ad executives, they come up with all the different slogans. Like, you know, do this, do this. Or like... You're thinking of, like... Bye. By menon.
我肯定懂。但这就像是他们，你知道的，那些广告高管，他们想出各种不同的标语。就像，你知道的，做这个，做这个。或者像是……你想的是，像是……再见。拜，门农（Menon）。
Menon. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. Smart. less. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
门农。聪明。聪明少干（Smartless）由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔姆杰夫和贝内特·巴比科100%有机纯手工打造。聪明。少干。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。